majority leader after months of partisan
stalemate
congress finally passed a cobin 19
relief bill totaling
900 billion dollars it includes direct
payment of 600
to most americans unemployment benefits
into march
and food and rental assistance it's far
from perfect i haven't met perfect
legislation since coming to washington
i wish we could have done even more but
i'm pleased we've done as well as we
could have done people like 79 year old
harold valentine can expect to see
government checks as early as next week
he says he could use it for groceries
but it's not enough for the christmas
gifts he'd like to send his grandkids
i'm not going to have that much pride to
say i don't want it
i need it you see a lot of need here
this is a definite
a lot of need here it is worse
it is getting worse more than 20 million
americans are receiving unemployment
benefits
with an additional 885 thousand
applying for aid during the first week
of december
then there are the three to seven
million americans who lost
jobs but never got unemployment benefits
because of
problems processing their applications
researchers say
some 8 million people in the u.s have
fallen
into poverty since may and half of
all small business owners say if things
continue as they are
they'll be forced to close permanently
within a year
in general you know it's been very
difficult to get aid
you know for for us for our businesses
as well as for our staff
definitely starting to feel like there's
no light at the end of the tunnel
this food pantry in washington has been
delivering up to a thousand bags of
groceries a day to struggling families
every little bit helps the communities
we serve and so you know a 600 dollar
stimulus payment for some families
i've had people who doing this pandemic
have actually lost relatives
and they've had to use some of their own
money for some of the barrel expenses
as the number of cobit 19 cases in the
u.s
surpasses 18 million the government is
racing to deliver
20 million doses of vaccine by the first
week of january
to save lives and the economy about to
receive its own injection
of stimulus to save livelihoods
hadijo castro al jazeera washington